Hi, Drew, I'm so happy to be here.
I'm such a huge fan, so this is quite,
quite, quite an exciting morning.
You were the front woman of a beloved franchise.
How do you feel about leaving Lara Jean now?
What do you feel about this final film?
I just watched it, I love it so much.
Sorry to bury the lead, you go.
You know, this story has been a huge part
of my life and it's changed my life.
I have played Lara Jean now for three movies
and I very much grew up with her.
And so it kind of feels like saying goodbye
to a part of yourself,
which is odd but I'm not saying goodbye
to my friends, which is good.
But yes, it's gonna be a lot.
I haven't quite fully processed yet, I must say.
How do you feel about how this closes out?
Because I think there's some really powerful life lessons
in this third installment.
You know, I feel very, very good.
For the third movie, I really wanted
to show that she could step out into the world
and make the choices for herself
that she believes is best for her regardless
of maybe it might not be the popular opinion
in her relationships.
But ultimately, you want to see a young woman kind of come
into her own and step out into this crazy world.
I just think it's a great way to go out
of something that people have lived with for years as well
and end it on this life lesson
I feel is very important.
I'm so excited for people to see it.
Man, is it satisfying.
Now, choosing yourself comes first,
but choosing love also, and I know your boyfriend,
Anthony, you guys have been together five years now?
Yes, we've been together for five years.
He is my everything.
I honestly don't know what I would do without him.
He's always been my rock, so five years strong, baby!
I am telling you your relationship is so authentic
and beautiful and can I just quickly run
through a quick dating advice tips that you have
that I think are so great?
Yes.
Okay, dates look a little different.
Do you have any fun tips for date nights at home?
So, I would say obviously, it's so important
to just turn off your phone
and spend time together.
We might be in the same room, but we're on the Zooms,
we're on calls, all these different things.
So to turn off kind of the noise
and just sit with each other and talk.
Okay, this sounds silly,
but we have this thing, it's called, literal,
it's literally called talk time.
And it's my favorite time
because it's like uninterrupted talking time.
So have some talk time for yourself.
I love it.
And then, dress up even if you're staying home.
I think that the majority, the majority of the meals
that we share together are in sweatpants.
But if you want to make it special,
obviously, dressing up makes it kind of feel a little, yes!
Like your beautiful, beautiful shirt.
Thank you, I think that's such good advice
and then there was also take a little drive?
Yeah, take a little drive and listen to music.
Like we will get take out and sit
in the car and eat it and listen to music
or watch something, like watch a movie in the car.
That's really nice 'cause it's a little bit
of a change of scenery.
So there's a couple ideas in there.
I love the ideas, I think they're great
incentivizations and I started driving around
with my girls when the pandemic started
'cause it was just the three of us
and we had nothing to do and nowhere to go.
So I would play albums and drive around with them.
Now Lana, before you go,
I thought we would take the opportunity
this Galentine's Day to highlight a gal-owned
business called Happy Box.
Happy Box is an online, curated build-a-box store
and it all started with someone sending her sister
a thoughtful package to lift her spirits up after a breakup.
And we thought we'd box up some happiness
for our VFFs and send a little Valentine's their way.
There's little candles and wine glasses.
Ooh, a gold wine opener.
Oh, and Compartes Chocolate.
Oh, you cannot go wrong with Compartes.
So all the VFFs are gonna get
$100 gift cards to HappyBoxStore.com
so you can build a little Galentine's Day box.
Yes!
I'm so happy for your success.
And it makes so much sense because you are smart,
beautiful, and we're all
loving watching you do your thing, thank you.
Thank you for having me
and I hope you have a beautiful Galentine's Day.
I will, and thank you for putting wonderful things
for us to watch out in the world.
We really need them right now.
We always need them, but now in particular.
To All the Boys: Always and Forever
is streaming now on Netflix.
(upbeat music)